u.s lawmakers in the house of
representatives are readying legislation
that could remove president trump from
office
house speaker nancy pelosi said that
they would first urge vice president
mike pence
to activate the 25th amendment declaring
the president
unfit for office now if that fails they
would take steps toward impeachment
five people including a police officer
died when a mob of trump supporters
stormed the capitol last week
a solemn moment on the streets of
washington dc
police officers paid tribute to their
colleague brian siknik
who died from his injuries after
president trump's supporters
invaded the capitol building on
wednesday
in his honor u.s speaker nancy pelosi
ordered flags to be flown
at half-mast but sunday will also be
remembered
in washington as the day that pelosi
sent a letter outlining her plans to try
to have trump removed from office
using words that pulled no punches
we will act with urgency she wrote
because this president represents an
imminent threat
the horror of the ongoing assault on our
democracy perpetrated by this president
is intensified and so is the immediate
need for action
the fear is that trump supporters will
try to stage another act of insurrection
before the inauguration
of joe biden on january the 20th
security has been tightened in the
capital
but pelosi's plans to have trump removed
are fraught with difficulties
firstly it's thought that vice president
mike pence is unlikely to lead any
attempt to have trump ejected by
activating the 25th amendment
declaring him incapable of carrying out
his duties
and with barely two weeks to go for
trump's presidency
impeachment is also thought to be tricky
with some democrats fearing it could
overshadow
joe biden's first 100 days in office
whatever the outcome it seems trump's
departure from office
will be as unconventional and tumultuous
as his entire presidency
let's get more we are joined by reporter
william
croft william tell us the democrats as
we've heard they're calling for
impeachment how realistic is it
impeachment itself is quite realistic
democrats can simply put the articles
the article i should say one article of
impeachment to the floor for a vote they
have the majority and they could impeach
the president
the trickier question is then when that
moves over to the senate for a trial
remember the senate is not in session
right now or come back after
inauguration day
could technically come back into session
but for all intents and purposes uh we
won't see any senate activity until next
week when biden is already president
that leaves the question of what the
point is of course there's a symbolic
aspect that the democrats want to show
that what happened on wednesday
that donald trump played a role in
inciting uh
does not stand cannot stand and then of
course there's also the practical aspect
um that if he were impeached and
convicted even after he were out of
office it could be possible then
for the senate to move uh to essentially
prohibit him
from ever running for public office ever
again
meantime we know that the incident has
been splitting the gop and i just like
to draw our viewers attention to the
fact that former california republican
governor
arnold schwarzenegger has spoken out
he's compared the mom that stormed
the us capital to the nazis
let's listen in and then we'll get your
reaction thereafter
now i grew up in austria i'm very aware
of crystal nacht
or the night of broken glass it was a
night of rampage against the jews
carried out in 1938
by the nazi equivalent of the proud boys
wednesday was the day of broken glass
right here in the united states
the broken glass was in the windows of
the united states capital
but the mob did not just shatter the
windows of the capital
they shattered the ideals we took for
granted
they did not just break down the doors
of the building that housed
american democracy they trampled the
very principles
on which our country was founded william
a dramatic
a horrific comparison there what do you
think his intention was
in making this comparison
well he of course wants to make uh make
his point that we don't really know
where we are
right now in the present time you know
looking back on history we have the
luxury of seeing the dots all connected
neatly lined up
for us you know today we we look back
and many historians say cristano after
1938
was the official beginning of the
holocaust of course back then there was
no way to know that
and so his warning is of course you know
take this seriously
uh because we don't know where this
might lead of course you don't have to
go to germany or austria for examples of
fascism in the united states
it has a long history of dealing with
fascist elements
including the 1930s itself was a very
tumultuous time
uh and if not for america's very strong
institutions and very strong leadership
especially under franklin delano
roosevelt the president at the time
the united states could have gone a very
different and dangerous direction i
think that's what schwarzenegger is
trying
to say right now that without the
institutions and the leadership
um these right-wing vigilantes or
militiamen whatever you want to call
them could
pose a very serious problem for the
republican for for democracy at large
and it's important also to remember that
there will indeed be a change
of leadership so it does differ in in
that way the two situations
um you know given that change of
leadership um from a
historical perspective schwarzenegger
says that trump will go down in history
as the worst
president ever in the united states
let's listen
i do believe that we must be aware of
the dire consequences
of selfishness and cynicism
president trump sought to overturn the
results of an election
and of a fair election he saw the coup
by misleading people with lies
my father and our neighbors were misled
also with lies
and i know where such lies lead
president trump is a failed leader he
will go down in history as the worst
president
ever the good thing is that he soon will
be as irrelevant as an old tweet
he uses the word irrelevant there
william perhaps pick up on that a little
bit because
ultimately 70 million u.s citizens did
vote for donald trump so where does that
leave the country
3 million 74 million americans voted for
donald trump of course not all of
them far-right militia men or white
supremacists but that undercurrent is
very strong as we saw
on wednesday at the capitol highly
organized uh
plan to storm the capital uh incited by
some of the remarks that donald trump
and his supporters his political
supporters made
so trump may be going away as of january
20th or sooner if democrats get their
wish
but trumpism is not uh and this is
something that the republican party has
to deal with what
is the future of that party we should
know that arnold schwarzenegger
is a longtime critic of donald trump he
and the president have gotten into uh
quite the twitter social media wars in
the past
especially when it came to immigration
and these kinds of things
so schwarzenegger would himself be
viewed as an enemy by these conspiracy
theorists that
only see donald trump as as their guy as
we're seeing now
uh with other senators and other
political officials and public officials
who were one staunch republican excuse
me trump allies
being heckled being threatened uh
because they're now seeing to break
to break ranks so this is a very serious
problem that the republican party is
gonna have to deal with but it's also
something they've been dealing with for
years
as the party has moved further right in
an effort to win elections and to hold
on to
uh it's a minority of
of of voters and and this is something i
have to go forward
as that party that split gets even more
extreme
and we're going to be dealing with that
the united states will be dealing with
that for
many more years to come regardless of
who's in charge
dw's william gluecroft breaking it all
down for us thank you
you